something or something how you doing man
is that a fanny pack you got alright
I've been waiting for those to come back
it's mad utility in the fanny pack yeah
are you okay are you always this proper
is that your man I was lying about you
having the white his boyfriend this
[ __ ] son huh
that's some white [ __ ] to tell me to do
[Applause]
I'm gonna tell you you gonna fire
whoever I know that works there Oh ain't
that a white flecks men yeah no no
that's that's hysterical I have no
swagger asking me about my 401k
[Applause]
I dare you nay I don't dare you I defy
you let's see if I give you tax advice
after the show I'm gonna ask what you do
at a certain point but right now I'm
just trippin on like it's almost like
you're not wearing the fanny pack
ironically like it's almost like it's
not a fashion package it's like there's
just so much utility how could I not I
can fit all my pocket change right here
just did you see this guy's standing at
Disney World like this thank God your
girl is black man your kid's gonna need
that they need it
Inez something dog son milk is your
spirit animal this is crazy it's like
I'm looking at a Snow Leopard
[ __ ] yetis I here in the middle
of the hauntings it's not cuz your skin
although the skin is very white
he literally oh my God he's so white I
swear to god he just unless I'm
misinterpreting he just did this
[Applause]
oh my god that's the widest expression
I've ever seen in my life
oh my god because it wasn't a soft
exhale so often exhales like my girl
gives me that all the time it wasn't
that it was like shoulders were involved
and he didn't finish the floor I role
cycle he stopped at the top it's the
widest expression I've ever seen in my
life man yo you [ __ ] you that do you
that white dude yo [ __ ] when people
complain about white people that's who
you their picture he did it again I know
huh I can't help it yo it's almost like
you're you're like her fetish almost
like actually like she was confiding in
a friend like I don't know why I just
really seemed to like white dudes and
then her friend was like I got just the
guy for you oh you like white dudes yo
let's go to the source
yeah you're like the tesseract of
whiteness this [ __ ] is just it all comes
out of this guy oh yeah I bet you were
darker before you met him I bet you you
she a nice cinnamon color now but I bet
she was dark before like look like she's
out of Nairobi or something and then she
hung out with this guy long enough and
now she says he's a nice little light
brown tone because a little soft a soft
brown great is normally like I said you
were white but nobody you actually dead
asked I wish you could turn around cuz
you look like a police officer that like
doesn't work out as much as a normal
police officer huh you might hate you
we'll get back to this white guy but can
you just stand up real quick and just
show it God tell me this guy hasn't
written you a ticket before okay that's
enough of you now
here's what makes here's what makes it
so great is 70% of the audience can't
see your face but they know how white
you are from the back like you don't
even need to look at your skin your
posture is so [ __ ] white he's like
this right don't have an erect ass back
that [ __ ] is the right angle in the
chair the back of the chair is my like
bruh give me some space stop is your
whole thing on me yo the sacrum to the
neck is just on me damn [ __ ] l1 to
the neck is just can't give me a second
to breathe again Coster for weak on this
back oh man oh I don't yeah listen I'm
not I don't want you to feel bad about
yourself because you're being a good
sport and I'm not trying to pick on you
but I have to comment on how white you
are there's nothing wrong with it but it
is funny